anyway so I've been licking your man's
butthole for dude the best anyways so of
all time anyway so I've been licking her
man's butthole for some time because he
he likes it a lot and I do it to him and
he comes to me and it happens
Jay-Z
dude her laugh is the Jay-Z laugh let's
see what Taryn Manning had to say I had
to pull over because I'm just like I
don't want to like cause crashes because
I'm just so rooted right now
so
rooted
I'm just like I don't know
right now
so
oh [__]
so high
the last man that I've been messing with
is a married man in every night oh [__]
well for about three nights in a row I
haven't seen this or even maybe there's
a night in between I was licking his
butthole
dude the meme of the [__] white guy
with a blonde hair
the [__] radio in the background dude
wow
[__] Neo moves up three spots to
number two this weekend
because he liked it
and I didn't mind doing it
I mean you know what does that mean like
you know yeah does that bother is that
weird yeah and that is what demons do
okay Kinks your Kink demons don't do it
also there's no demons so let's move on
hey what's first of all we are 41
seconds into this three minute and 30
video
what where could this go
so
so I was so in love so I thought so I
could buy this gentleman a boat and I
and I brought cash to put a down payment
down like I really loved him I was like
yeah it's like we're into the same thing
oh hold on hold on hold on so he's
married
you were going to buy him a boat
I really loved him and I was like we're
into the same thing does that mean
eating his butthole that's the thing
well that's not love you know
and his wife because he's married and I
feel so bad because not I I can't stand
her okay
I can't stand her her his wife
because she wasn't even like wait what
you've been messing with my man she said
you lunatic you get out of my life or
I'll get an RO on you well she was mad
so gotta forgive her I'll put your ass
in jail
there we go there's a lot of information
but I'm the lunatic right well yeah
no I'm just single very single right
well
and he came to me so this may be all
made up though that's the good thing
about that
one thing lady you want to put me in
jail I'll put you in jail in jail for
what your head will be spinning don't
you ever threaten me nice I actually I
will show you how I do I actually like
this don't you ever threaten me when
your husband came to me to get his
butthole licked dude this is the most
gangster [__] ever threaten me again
Leanne this is Gangster dumbass and now
I'm a turn man
I cannot believe you
leave you lost it
lost it not I oh dude she just been
watching like so much tutors you know
not I I brought your husband
poor beats we drove all
that we had so much fun he had his hand
on my leg the whole time most of the
time
finger banging me I'm not gonna lie I'm
not gonna lie anymore about about it
anymore no I had no Underwood's on and
and every time like in his fingers and
you're to buy him a boat
to buy him a boat
he went on a boat he's gonna have a boat
and get his buddies and I was gonna buy
it for him gonna call the boat the bud
eater
on the back
and you're coming after me nah it ain't
gonna happen lady oh my you made it
here's the thing you made a huge mistake
she said the name of
you're dusted dusted I ain't scared of
you you should be scared of me well I I
hear you here's the thing about that is
she didn't make anything any word she
didn't make anything worse for anybody
but herself like she didn't even say the
people and I'm not saying she should she
shouldn't you ate someone's butthole and
their wife's mad and that's honestly the
end of that that's really the end of
that you ate someone's butthole the
life's mad well look let buying on three
bygones you know what I mean like men
they keep [__] up but also you hate a
married man's butthole so it's like you
were gonna buy him a boat so it's like
okay you know let's just kind of Move On
Now what's happening is you look the
wife got mad and she started yelling at
you saying [__] you and this that the
other thing look that's bad but also let
it go find another butthole to eat you
know what I mean there's out there's men
out most most men would let you eat
their butthole uh and I mean that I
don't know probably a lot of you are
like no not most men some men it's a
weird King maybe it's not dude I
guarantee good men can be talked into
the [__] from bye bye by a woman
you know
you ever see men around sex they go like
this
can I eat your butthole what no couldn't
eat your ball no let me hear your
butthole
what's it feel like I don't know if it
was good people say it feels good really
no let me in your butthole all right
that's how it would be
he found another butthole to eat because
at that point it's not about the man I
understand
it's about the man if you're going to
give a BJ or sex of course it is because
you want to be in love but butthole
you're all back there and stuff you're
not even facing the guy
he could fart on you it's just all
disrespectful it's not about the guy
it's about the Kink so just do that with
any guy
you know
my heart goes out to tearing Manning
though I feel like she probably needs
some help